giannis 18 points at the rim high field
goal percentage but embiid
doing the job envy thought he got fouled
on the rip through
adeta kumba laked out of four
and they have the worst defensive field
percentage
at that range also so it's definitely an
area
he makes up for the two free throws
back and he does it's 12-5 milwaukee
leading new york surprisingly his first
in the western conference
62nd in his career from behind
underneath
knocked it away packed and ready to fire
lebron headed
knocked away from behind gary rozier
makes it a one-point game again
halfway through our fourth quarter oh my
goodness he's in hillman
seven flushes and this is the emphatic
one my goodness
great defense here by kcp who push off
the three what
another one oh my goodness four
of six gets a jump shot
it's going to be lights out heading
third quarter
pass down
first to giannis trailing ciaco not
quitting on the play and get that shot
out of here
[Music]
[Applause]
the shot goes down
he's trying to find that saddle
get to the old town road
[Applause]
18 points to the rim high field goal
percentage but fb
doing the job and thought he got fouled
on the rip through
adeta kumbo
but he got hit so he was a little late
coming up the floor was left to bias
on an island the last place in the nba
you want to be
look at that oh my goodness the
extension he takes off again
from the free-throw line middleton
step back yes
[Applause]
yes
yes he did i told you it was good
wow down to the ground off the ball on
the weak side
involving that first ball harris takes
it away
ahead
beautiful basketball first a great
defensive play give me that cp3
get it early get it back watch that
bounce pass no look number
from george hill and then get out the
weigh-in backboard
swaying monster jam
what up it's your boy adam lefkow do you
like that content i know you like that
content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report